hi everyone I'm zorraine and I'm Ed and
not just it's like God I think they're
used to you being on our stream right
now and this is House of Horrors the
stream where we play horror games on a
weekly basis
like a great show idea how did you come
up with
I should totally pitch the stream idea
yeah and then the rest is live streams
are fun
we used to stream every day but anyway
today we're playing The Forest which is
currently in uh Alpha it just got
released last month I believe
um yeah it's very early days for the
alpha in fact we're looking at a screen
right now that lets us know when the
next
um Alpha Build release is so my
experience some jankiness but yeah this
is still like one of the top selling
games on Steam that's right it's like uh
well it's
where you play as a person in a forest
okay yeah granted we don't know a lot
about this game I haven't played it more
than like 10 minutes or so okay I
haven't played it at all so this will be
a nice learning experience like say
daisy or rust or something but if you've
played the forest before give us some
good tips
otherwise
otherwise otherwise
anyway so let's get into it okay so this
is developed by end of night games uh
who I believe this uh is their first
title that they're working on and as it
says it is in Alpha yeah so there are a
bunch of uh X special effects visual
effects developers or artists so that's
why it looks really good at least in the
screenshots
animation and loading screen and loading
screen
it's good font yeah
yeah yes so does it usually take this
long to load yes it does okay there's a
lot of sick Graphics that you know
flying be all alone
that's uh that's really oh no oh no I'm
a kid he's holding my arm get off me
strange times I'm gonna say that's your
sign this is a really good flight it's
really empty it seems like stretch out
take a nap
what's going on
race positions with freaking like oxygen
mask
and I was waiting for them to drop this
shitty flight it's not like like in the
title cards they give you
oh no that's terrible do we need to eat
him hey look some guys crunch
oh that's okay he's gonna take care of
him see we didn't need to worry
this is a nice game uh
do we win I think we won
all right I'm on low health
yo but you're freaking bleeding
everywhere
um you need to find something to eat yes
she died she got axed
um
dudes dude come on okay so on the bottom
left it says you can use the X cut down
trees or dismember enemies
um and you need health and food it's all
right I just picked up some airplane
food did you eat it yeah I think oh yeah
yeah so you're stomach in the bottom
right I think I just consume things I
don't really like you can't pick them up
or you can add them to your backpack so
hit either check out your backpack but
I'm just like like hitting e on
everything right yeah and he just
conceals something can we take a look at
that leg for a second
so did he just fall back in his chair
gross see if you can dismember the leg
this is important
well like we said it's it's Alpha so
maybe we should search the plane for
supplies oh geez okay okay so if there's
anything
there's something soda a lot of soda
this is a lot like Daisy where like
everything you drink is like a soft
drink
airplane food which I can consume but
not stalks
all right so check out backpack for a
second let's see oh it's like one of
like that's a nice spread yeah alrighty
survive um so I'm assuming we can read
the survival guide I see Elida and lots
of drinks oh we don't need to read the
survival guide oh yeah we'll be fine we
know this five oh no I'm stuck I like I
like that you can see your feet any
first person game where you can see your
feet it's a um a tick in my book really
it's it's all about
immersion immersion
so
I'm gonna collect all these yeah I guess
we should do scaven that's the first
thing we should do it's like dead stuff
pick up everything that you come across
in the first 10 minutes that's right I
don't think we can become oh God I'm
headless it's good you're looking down
try looking up
twist
so it's a
oh wow
that's awesome so you've got a tennis
ball I'm guessing that might be good for
a distraction oops I don't have it
anymore but when you get your dog um
companion you can play fetch with it
oh
so this is like a super realistic
version of Don't Starve
um there's one thing that I did do in
the five minutes I uh played this was
chopped down a tree and the tree
chopping is pretty good yeah yeah well
um let's go find that tennis oh there's
a lot of stuff around here actually yeah
well I mean a plane just crashed and all
this [__]
this is how the TSA handles your baggage
did you know the TSA searched my bag
it's just like all the times that I went
on a plane this E3 my bag got searched
about TSA how do you know because they
include a slip in your bag it's like I
researched your bag
and everything's like out of order now
when your system's screwed yes I'm sorry
yeah so can't carry any more raw fish so
you have raw fish
um and it's telling you to learn the
basics of survival so Press B to open
the survival book oh my
God all right so this is pretty
comprehensive
so I'm going to assume this is yeah so
this is the Res recipe list
right
looks like it so oh so it's like placing
like selecting a recipe making sure you
have the materials and then placing it
in the world
all right well
so the first thing to do is build a
shelter Fire Man Building A Fire they
make it look so easy just like click to
place your fire
um what else what's step three
hang on uh where
um in the the red tab the basics
so okay then we need to worry about food
oh okay
okay so the blackberries are bad and the
oval leaved blueberries are good
you just have to look at what the birds
eat that's that's what I was taught oh
really yeah so if Birds gonna eat it
it's good for you because they don't die
so wait so the first protocol should be
a shelter we should build a shelter and
gather supplies for a shelter right all
right so right so I need what do I need
for a shelter so we need sticks six
sticks four rocks and four logs do we
have logs I haven't picked up any longer
okay let's cut down a tree it's gonna be
sweet all right
what do I just whack it yeah
uh this should be like a cutting line
that appears there you go so you need to
kind of Move Yourself around the tree to
to sever it on all ends
man
Lumberjack simulator
it was a plaid shirt like deals
my hands are so bloodied off it's
amazing
hey so um how many wax do I need to get
here we go Timber
see check this out this is awesome holy
crap except then it just like
[__]
oh that's the best but still it's
probably impressive like the Magics oh
man I can't count oh okay so you can't I
must be like carrying too much crap so
you got sticks or maybe you just can't
carry logs because they're so huge right
so whether how do I build my thing
oh hang on so maybe just maybe why don't
we just take all the logs through
clearing somewhere where we can build
like a nice I like this area I can see
very far
um aphanati said
um that tree chopping was so cool until
hashtag video games
very good
um all right let's go back can I Sprint
yes I can where do you have stamina
did you not log
the plates might hunger faster if I do
oh neat okay that makes sense yeah jog
off the fat maybe you should make a
shuffle right next to the plane
it's a it's like a nice sunny clearing
and it's just materialized out of thin
air and I like how they eat um little
logos of Pac-Man too but anyway
full pack
man all right okay so it was fun stop
turn around look in the distance turn
around turn around 180 180.
how did you know that because I saw that
I saw the movie oh okay so I'm gonna
well one sprinting
not towards us though right
he's really gunny hello
so I don't know what the eight
okay oh wow okay
so can you collect the caucus of that
rabbit yeah or I ate it straight away
all right so I see
wait a second
when did you kill that guy I didn't kill
anyone
can you can you hack off his limbs well
so I assume
um I'm gonna guess that part of the
strategy about shelter is to place it in
a location where those crazy tall guys
are not
oh I'm going to
what was that did you eat a poison Berry
but they're blue are you sure those are
the good ones check the survival books
it says blue with oval shaped leaves
um so I don't think yeah that's Urban
lived blueberries
yeah they look like that they're in
bunches indigo color okay
are you just tripping over the bush no
but I don't think
anyway we should build a shelter build a
shelter or go hunt down those guys okay
I don't think I don't think that's a
good idea
um where's my other log gone oh there it
is it's sinking into the marsh clipping
um how many looks did I need again
four okay so you might be chop down on
the tree so might you just dropped down
a tree that's closer to the oh that
clearing I'm pretty
I'm pretty sure heaps of logs dropped
down
okay there's one okay you're right and I
and I see one just ahead there too okay
so we're doing all right this reminds me
a lot of um mir's Marta oh that game
that one came that game was a bit slow
for my liking though I think this one
jumped straight into the open world
aspect much faster these might have I
wasn't really about surviving though I
think it was about I don't know
triangulating and finding a um cure for
your illness
that didn't have shelter and crafting in
the same kind of
detail then I think the forest is
supposed to have yeah I think I feel
like they're going for a very much
survivor-esque type deal all right we
got four logs we haven't died yet so I'm
I'm pretty happy with our progress our
shelter is made
wait a minute sick all those Minecraft
skills came in Handy's rain I know I
know so
so does it have to be colored for me to
place yeah I'm gonna assume sir
what if I tried
oh wait so you've placed the blueprint
that's a really
it's like naughty oh okay so so I think
what you need to do is actually oh can I
can
can I so I think what you need to do is
you need to place the blueprint first
and then bring the materials into the
blueprint okay so can you pick it pick
it up and like kind of readjust it so
we're not like sleeping in the middle of
it well
um if I hit a all it does is a place
another oh [__] really try and building
another one try putting another
blueprint down
this is horrific this is it's in the
garage terrifying house
on the grass put it on the grass because
the grass is more comfy to sleep on all
right all right okay here we go
yeah it's taking it out of my inventory
it's actually really neat that's a
that's a neat um
I got the log
sick that's awesome I like that that is
pretty cool
it's completely like real life that's
right you know it's building from the
bottom up
I should stop using sprinters making me
hungry as in the character not me well
can you just hack at it
all right
um the bird is taunting you so we're
gonna have to kill the bird a little
later but we need a couple more logs so
we need four more logs and two more
three more logs
well it says four out of eight on the
thing oh sorry yes I am looking at the
bottom left which is incorrect what the
hell is that minus three out of 12.
okay all right sticks
what was that
sorry all right um
um you can hold more than two logs
apparently
apparently shoulders
all right let's chop some trees down
you can hold multiple logs people are
saying
so
yeah I can
hmm I'm getting awfully hungry
maybe we should forage no no let's get
our shelter built first and then fire
and then we can because you pick up that
rabbit carpet didn't you
yeah I do so once we get our shelter
going we can get a fire belt and then we
can cook a freaking
um
oh all those logs fell off the cliff no
no Mac
all right it's all right
so how do I pick up more than one
oh whoa neat this guy is filmed
he definitely lifts that's awesome okay
learn something new every day so what
else do we need one more log yeah we
need a couple more so you're gonna chop
down another tree you're gonna go pick
up
so just make sure I I don't think
jumping off the cliff is a particularly
good idea in a survival game
um and also you're on low energy
apparently eat something or get some
rest
you want to eat the starfish
it's a delicacy in some countries what
what's the starfish doing the edge of a
cliff nowhere near the water
these are the questions that you must
ask
also I also noticed that they there are
these creepy like totem poles just just
to your right oh yeah so I'm gonna
assume
um once we go past it yeah we'll be in
trouble well let's not go past there for
now
and lift
oh that was the other look I couldn't
so I can only carry two
you'll get better well you know going up
these Cliffs sides isn't very
challenging
um mega pick 99 suggests that you eat
the chocolate or food you have now
before your Energies
oh sick okay
so we can rest to fill energy or we can
eat something our energy is blinking low
chocolate bar
okay so energy and fullness are two
different stats
what's the red bar then I'm gonna what's
that temperature that might just be your
health
raw rabbit I wonder if it keeps for
let's just say it does all right so
let's build a fire
all right Next Step to survival build a
fire
something tells me building a fire on
the grass isn't a good idea it's wet
grass so it won't
put it so what do we need seven leaves
and
well I've got all the sticks I like to
pick up individual leaves
slightly different but I can see how you
got the mixture
is all around me can't I just grab those
I'm sure if you just match it you'll be
fine what if you just chop down like a
little sapling
oh he gets Twigs no leaves sticks
how do we get leaves I'm sure there's
leaves around here somewhere also I just
found another suitcase thing which
there's probably some leaves in there
which
where is it
nope
wigs twig
so you're sure you can't just pull them
off
no where do I find leaves oh wait what
it says your Gala leaves aren't stat at
the bottom there is Flushing oh my God
logs is also minus three out of eight
which is very bizarre how do I have
negative Vlogs oh oh look at the turtle
down down it's camouflage no he ran
forward
I I thought I saw something
yeah
oh that bird got all up in my face
oh so are those the poison berries or
those the good berries
I think they're the good berries oh look
my energy bar went on peeps
um
damn it Serene we're gonna get some
waves all right all right I'm working on
it oh look it's an iguana
I think you should kill it and also
uh ask it before it sleeves iguana sorry
it's either you or me buddy it's a game
of smoke
come back I feel we're getting off task
here this is all right this is
vis-a-vis
let's go find more Lee
leaves
I like I like how the the log shopping
was like very detailed that like just
picking up a leaf is
no no this is oh Lee's collected what
yeah yeah a little pop-up just came up
on the left so you have a few so you've
got plenty of leaves now we just need to
uh be more observant
something I'm very good at
luckily there aren't there aren't any
cut scenes in this skip
so it's actually turning into night
it's all right we've got
it light it
gliders oh
yeah you need a shower
we should build a shower all right let's
build a shower all right so
all right so now that sorted we just
need to worry about food and exploring I
guess
um you know I guess the only other goal
that I can think of is trying to find
your kid
that's pretty good in case you want to
compare your place do dude who
killed the cabinet like out of a bear
like nothing it only takes 35 logs and
14 sticks it's a pretty good deal I know
I just have to chop down every single
tree around here and then I'll have
enough vlogs
I think that should be our number one
priority
you just walked into the fire
well can you like stop drop and roll
can you like stop
oh man this is
yeah all right so what's our plans right
what's our plan right so it looks like
we need um well we have a shelter we
have fire what's that
that's just a rock uh that's in
petrified wood maybe a little by the
glow of the fire
all right so our next priority I reckon
is to build a house
so
I reckon I think we should look for
clues for our child our missing child
that's what I would do if I was a parent
who
got into a
a disastrous plane crash all right
let's go back to the plane and look for
Clues encountered a terrifying
naked man
he wasn't completely naked
um
we might need to worry about the
darkness
it's telling you later
you lie
oh you took you're holding wet full of
fire to get dry also now it's raining
maybe we should just call it for the
nine and rest up until tomorrow morning
I agree we need to be at full strength
to fight those men and get our child
back
we'll see this fight going well me too
um lint Bella in chat suggests building
a Blu-ray player so we can uh let's
entertain ourselves
and everyone thinks we're going to get
ambushed and die horribly well have some
Faith with everyone
asleep
do I do I just oh okay okay you can just
eat your oh there we go I can see catch
some z's okay
all right so early morning
good now it's pretty good fire go and
fight people for our children
um let's see well
there's a totem poles and I saw some the
dudes we saw before they were like
coming from that oh there's a bird on
our house
isn't that nice it's like Mary Poppins
except you have an ax and you're a
sociopath
how do I cook the fire okay let's see
oh look it's cooking Edmund
it's very good to me
you didn't even have to skin it
it looks skinned already I must have
skinned it when I killed it
down you reckon or do you think we need
to equip that like well actually can we
build weapons I mean we have an ax but
can we at least go like a spear like
fashion or rock out of things well I see
something that might be a weapon too
maybe we're just not good enough for
that oh Jesus Okay small garden geez so
we can grow on food this is awesome all
with the door with Windows
where do I get Gloss from
um apparently you don't need gloss
judging by the materials so you can
place traps happy birthday okay
um and a new strap that
can probably trap rabbits
Oh I thought it was for people
that's more
that's more a log holder so you can keep
your logs in place that's awesome
this game has it all
right well it doesn't look like I can
build any weapons any
and I've covered all the bases so what
we we only have our ax and traps
pretty much it look at it take a look at
the effigies
so oh you need seven Lambs oh God I do
need to collect people what the [__]
okay
so I if one of the averages for does
anyone know what they have to Do's are
for let's find out let's build one and
see what happens hey
build a tank
so you still need the limbs so we're
gonna need to hunt down some guys and
chop off their limbs well can't I just
chop off the bodies like the bodies
there was yeah there was a body there
wasn't there there was a couple of
buddies around
them well
is there you don't have a map do you
um so if we do travel we need to kind of
keep
um
uh keep our sort of
orientation
and check so walk straight
um yeah you're right okay so I would use
uh scare away the mutants it says chat
so oh really
um ideally we'd want some near our camp
um
well if I just
sorry lady okay maybe that's yeah
am I to find some of those cannibal
bodies that was the duder who was around
here before yeah around here yeah I
think it was at the rear of the plane
oh I see someone's hand
no way it's just a good one
damn it I get stuck under that Wing okay
okay um he was here somewhere I'm gonna
just
say he was a figment of our imagination
do you think he got up and went on a
walk it's possible he was just a sleeper
a spy
sleeping spy great and he went to go
telling us well I need three heads three
hands and two feet
well
let's wander off an interaction all
right so so let's from the plane let's
go house let's just keep walking
straight and don't turn what whatever
you do just don't
okay we'll just walk straight for a
while and see what we can do no look I
can still see where my home is like
because of the indicator right I don't
think that disappears
too easy
easy life easy Wares
would you tell me to make our own gold
Serene hey the water
well what if I stick to the coast yeah
that might be an easy
way wait a minute yeah
um there's a boat down there my personal
supplies in the boat maybe we can fix
the boat and like leave the island
we will see you later okay move on
um
I'm pretty sure you can like jump from
like a small house you should give it a
shot all right YOLO
your health just went down dramatically
I'm just
maybe we should eat an energy bar
Chop Chop you're healthy not going there
no it did not it's been pretty low all
along actually so like okay let's check
out the bird I don't think it Regens on
its own
Birds
oh crap it's another starfish oh man
crabs
um actually can't use it or for anything
I know that seems like something I'd
want to take with me as someone stranded
on an island
do you think I can go fishing
I'm gonna say yes
I'm drowning you probably need to craft
a fishing pole first though
all right well this looks like it I'm
surprised you haven't been attacked yet
um people are suggesting we kill a shark
um okay oh Lucifer Jones says right
click cloth and alcohol and bottle to
make a Molotov I'm not sure if trolling
try and put it into the cloth in the
middle
combine
Molotov nice thank you uh Lucifer well I
wonder what else I can combine
stick and ax
no no maybe you have to get rid of the
molotov first oh yeah
oh The X can't be used
to come stick and lighter
no
no stick and leaf
um
yes get out remove
D all right all right shut up and bags
hit them with your Hatchet yes we have
done that
um how do I get back up yeah
you're gonna need to oh that's okay I
can scale now don't worry I've got this
wow I'm strong and fast and agile
no no your Energy's completing quite
quickly
more sticks okay home was that way so if
I keep going this way
theoretically speaking I should come
across new things soon right yeah I mean
we have food
don't we
50. pots
they look like it
uh we have booze and soda well we might
have to hunt some more rabbits we wanted
to make a little snare trap oh my
rabbit's still like
cookie
rabbit jerky okay so there are huts this
is a good this is intriguing hey people
oh look is it can you crouch yeah yeah
so you can Crouch think all right so
more luggage is good and there's a man
just looking at us Hello nice to hurt
you I don't think I would walk towards
him because he's obviously facing us try
and suck around back and sneak up on him
if anything
why because that's how you do that's how
you do stealth takedowns Jesus play
video games
I think I should approach him from the
front I wouldn't want someone to sneak
up if there is if we'll sneak up to them
and if there isn't like a talk
um interaction that pops up we
accidentally hit all right
around oh really okay well he's alone at
least are they like meditating what's he
doing is that a stick of dynamite
Flair oh I'm gonna assume it's a flat
hello
um friendly friendly you friendly
what is he what's he got in his head
it's got like a weapon made out of hands
you friendly
he hasn't done anything to us
all right I'm Gonna Leave Him be and
we're just gonna scat out this area
you're too nice you should never play
Daisy
it's US versus them man I won't be the
first one to throw the punch
all right we'll let them capture us
first how about that yeah and then we'll
get it we'll get better Revenge
that's not a dude
wait what's that person doing
um everyone's telling you to ask him man
um he was the one who shot down your
plane says uh razama
um and Mary says you're way too nice to
survive in this game
and too nice to survive in life I would
say so we're still here wait are those
other passengers
take a look at that
I am looking at it so maybe she oh God
that's not she's skewered with a tennis
racket
and bound with tennis balls and why all
those balls bouncing all of a sudden
take a look at the face take a look at
the face
so was that guy
ugh it's actually really wow that's
that's not a her I'm pretty sure yeah
um so maybe that guy in the distance
actually is also dead but he was
breathing wasn't he yeah he was moving
okay
hold on before we go back to that guy go
left and look at that thing
right there the face let's let's get a
good look at the face say
all right I'm glad we did this just okay
so pretend that's your high school
friend High School best buddy and just
pretend that that guy strong his or her
face up like that
now don't run up to him stealthy
well oh my God okay well this is going
well okay
don't stop
Duke Duke I need for juking double tap
oh nice
okay awesome this is this is a good
progress I'm gonna progress I'm covered
in blood it says wash it off to avoid
infection that's all interesting Hey
where's his head where did he go okay
we've got some legs but where's the head
in the arms too
oh really maybe they just clipped off
into the um maybe they rolled down a
hill there's the arm look down there
okay where's the hair
hmm
oh is that it was that a rock
ain't killers
insane I'll have to take a look at our
inventory again
um
he was just another ball of booze yeah
hold on what's that a little um cloth
and teeth great great that's awesome
maybe we can like um sew teeth onto our
ax to make it more effective
pills
rock rock where's the head I need the
head
seems like a waste
it's okay we'll just find his friends
and family and then
now I feel bad don't say that
that's all right he killed my high
school friend
oh oh it could see if you can chop off
that body
I thought I saw someone okay
oh awesome
the moral of the story is the Real
Horror is mankind very nice
so you you can't carry more legs
oh there you go so we've got a whole
body now this is great yeah
take a look at the recipe
um
it was three three arms three heads
Jesus all right it's a lot of heads
that's a lot of heads can I just take
these heads can we get a good look at
the inside of that person's guts
this is House of Horrors man this is
what you do guys do right
yeah look at the insides of people
I'm not even sure what I'm picking up
there man look at all the stuff we can
salvage in
so much stuff
I can't believe they stole all these
tennis balls was it were you gonna like
tennis camp or something there are so
many tennis walls in this game
so you're taking your kid to tennis camp
and the plane got shot down by cannibals
well it's true because the other guy was
killed by like 10
these guys just really hate tennis
they were upset at Australia's dominance
the worldwide tennis scene very good
more tennis balls see what I mean
it's annoying because like when carrying
a tennis ball I can't put it in my
pocket or anything yeah I just have to
hold it you haven't crafted the tennis
shorts yet all right
and a box for storing the balls
maybe at some point we can craft a
tennis ball server so it can just
automatically shoot balls or a trap it
shoots yeah yeah okay didn't rain this
is a great idea I'm glad we're getting
our ball quitter in yep
can we just pick up an existing effigy
off right yeah
oh Jesus Christ
you're a Moscow there we go
oh he does
oh I like the I like the crouching while
you swing for more distance
I like that it's a fish
God
oh
Jesus you just rocket Jones are there
that's awesome so okay you really need
to eat you gotta pick up pick up the
head if you can I am it's rolling away
yeah yeah limbs Oh no I got too many
limbs I don't care anymore um we need to
Upper energy
the guys really smart
I
didn't hear anything okay like you
didn't even hear him approached us he
just came out of nowhere see that's how
you do it you're supposed to stealth it
so we need to wash our self to avoid
infection but how do you wash yourself
do I jump I'm guessing I just dive in
the ocean oh what is what does that guy
have in his mouth looks like
it's like nice
they they're really creative with these
um
you could say that hold on turn around
I'll throw someone in the trees it could
be wrong
yeah there so yeah I see someone walking
there's two of them okay I think I need
to get out there yeah I get overwhelmed
yeah
maybe we can
um
somebody suggest seeing whether you can
use the Boost to wash yourself
um I don't think that's how people
usually take booze maybe you can only
drink it yeah
um can you as someone's suggesting equip
a limb let's see if we can use a leg as
a fighting tool oh my God all right
that's gross oh man that guy needed a
Pity really bad Jesus Christ
because I have many pennies for
cannibals who knows
all right are you gonna watch are you
going to wash yourself yeah
yeah
um
yeah let's try and go to a beach
I
think the ax seems like the more logical
twist it's probably more effective yeah
that too unless they get scared of
seeing their own limbs oh that might be
a interesting
you can just use the head and just like
throw it oh my God actually yeah you
can't do it
oh good a head is not an effective way
why is this even a thing
all right I think I think you're clean I
think you're clean because I didn't even
go because the prompt isn't there
anymore oh yeah
it's a dried off
that's awesome
um combine ax and leg people are saying
no you can't combine oh right well it
can't be used for
okay never mind
it was glowing it was very strange
um Matt Chu suggests suggests killing a
shark
I don't think I can do that but it
doesn't seem like a good idea I don't
know Island over there is another boat
yeah it must be I wonder if I can dive
oh sorry what are you doing checking out
the island okay
swimming with an accident is a good idea
we should have Telly built our shelter
on the island oh my gosh
to bring all those logs over there
though also it doesn't seem like it's
getting any closer
in fact
it seems like it's remaining at the same
distance try swimming backwards and see
if you're going away from sure
we can't go the island
I don't know
oh no
okay okay all right okay visual tricks
uh you find the polar bear on the island
and kill it Jack is only on us to go
back lots of lost jokes in chat right
now oh okay I never I've never seen lost
okay so hopefully there's like a shotgun
or something I guess you could say those
references are lost on me that's it
stream over
all right wait what's can you loot it no
I can't do anything it's really
interesting
break it down break down
man does that mean there's someone else
on the island with you
that's really strange
is it so is it just rocks around there
oh yeah it looks like it
is there anything else in the island
give it a really good one server
something tells me no
no
look at my
looks like you're sliding along
all right let's the sun is yeah we gotta
get home
all right time for the long run back
time for the long swim it's a good thing
this guy is a fit
tennis athlete
he can just swim long distance
while holding an act raw holiness
run
he has really good like axing form
he knows exactly how many logs are
required for a shelter
just as a book though
that is also true
maybe I should bring a survival book
with me next time we go flying someone
that seems like a good idea
I wonder um
if there is an end state in the current
Alpha like whether we can win the alpha
um
something tells me no I mean like it's
an open world survival game right it
might not even have any
what well I'm gonna assume once you find
your kid and get out of it it's gonna
judging from them yeah there is a
narrative
element in there oh man yes Mary makes
good point that your rabbit is going to
be so overcooked oh no
hi Mary you can't you can't eat burnt
rabbit you can't eat too much carbon
it's bad for you
maybe we can use the chocolate maybe we
can poison the Cannibal's food
um
yeah maybe if you unequip the ax can you
can you open your backpack
yeah and spread it out on the thing
I think it's all right
let's grab the head wait you can combine
the head
oh maybe I can't craft well yeah I think
that would make sense it makes more
sense it makes more sense than being
able to open your backpack
oh no it's all over Edmund the darkness
has arrived do you think they can look
at that light up ahead of the top of the
cliff on the right
oh wait no it's gone never mind it must
have been just some Twilight yeah
um actually quite nice I feel safer
staying in the water
what's with the cracks do you see the
cracks I do see the cracks
I think it must just be part of the rock
texture oh okay right that'll start in a
freak me a bit um equip the legs for
double swimming speed suggests
um
this is very good take it lighter
oh this is the boat that was at our
shore
it's got all Bic lighters always
reliable yeah so reliable
um if I run into anything I'm bolting
straight into the water
assuming I mean to climb up a cliff I
know but like I'm assuming the
cannonballs cannibals can't swim right
oh no they look pretty fit
Gail Cliffs I forgot
wait a minute are you serious this guy's
amazing oh
God oh no did he die for real oh he just
died that's okay
when was the last time I saved too long
ago how does it say wait what happens
now
turn your lighter back on
we're in a cave of some sort yeah I've
gathered as much
someone must have brought us here
someone or something
well I've got all my stuff still yeah
you get your ax that's pretty good is
there anything you can eat to
drink some sodas you can use the flare
as a light source you really wanted to
no
um
Christopher Jones says two times you end
up in the cave after you quote unquote
die right okay
okay also there's heaps of luggage in
here yeah so this must be like where the
cannibals live I'm gonna assume that
they just took you away hmm
so what they left me here
well save it for later
everyone at once
some people just need to have priority
over others right
you're gonna need to get a new lighter
that's all right I'll just go down to
the store
and buy one
what do I
and somebody's gonna jump out yeah I'm
gonna I'm just gonna assume
you see
maybe she's the flare
membership save the flare we should say
well that's what I wanted to do okay how
about I just swing my ax forward as I go
stay away I'm gonna swing my ax and if
you run into it it's not my fault oh hey
look exactly it's all what about oh man
my other high school friend
your other tennis buddy your doubles
partner
she was really nice
look her twin sister is up ahead they
got her too not the awesome twins
oh God no I feel like this is leading me
out
is this you're going towards the house
icon so I'm gonna assume that yeah
forward
yeah you're overwhelmed you should run
I'm running I'm running you still got a
lot of energy so you should be okay
damn rocks getting in my way
I feel like there should be some
Traditions jump on the table for some
tribal so let me out Olivia can you open
the door no I can't oh
can you exit uh go right right
nope oh yeah yeah oh hey yeah okay okay
um are they following you they weren't
very close when you looked back
I don't know but I'm stuck ax actually
way out all right
all right is that the other side of the
wall of the I can't tell the house is
now over there so I guess so
crutch crutch jump oh there we go bunny
hop
are they not fire
wait what's something right is that a
bigger ax
okay it is a bigger ax get it
all right ax leveled up okay so this is
definitely not where we were no and I
feel like he's looking at me so I'm
gonna turn my lighter off
you can just hit l oh right
so you're gonna be sneaky yeah let's do
this
oh I'm stuck in the wall
what is that is that like a health kit
money money I think it's money it's
money yeah
remember there's a good in-game economy
where we can buy out the animals
I haven't known as shoes what have they
got
they're um there's a guy crouched over I
don't think he's okay
yeah I don't think they're having fun so
that was three days
well that went swimmingly
um at least I didn't die by like
environmental causes right right she
just baked again okay there we go
are we are we gonna try again or should
we go let's give it one more go giving
no it's all me no okay all right let's
do this
oh
all right
so what do we learn that time zone we
learned that
um you shouldn't try climbing cliffs in
the Darkness at night time
we learned that if something's running
at you you should kill it straight away
or run away okay let's trade away and we
also learned that
um let's see sometimes if you kill
people they drop three heads instead of
one
we want that three heads better than one
yep yep
all right so what's our game plan this
time
uh the game plan is
no this is the narrative setup but we've
already seen it yeah but maybe something
different will happen this time
really Edmund like we'll fly to tennis
camp and then we'll be yeah it will be a
tennis game it'll turn to a tennis
simulator
don't get freaked out our kid's pretty
freaked out
he looks like he's having a good time
let's get a little Bobby
everything's gonna be okay oh Bobby
his little Rainbow t-shirt
okay
better than us oh there we go
all right
so the suggestion is this time really
the suggestion is this time for us to
build our shelter
near the pond area the pond area is
there a pond
hey
it's my kid
um I don't know if you know but that's
actually our child sorry
uh don't forget everyone if you do want
to join the conversation but you don't
have a Twitch account you can tweet at
us with the hih live hashtag and we'll
be reading all the tweets
scavenge the crap out of this plane
BioShock Infinite style Jesus Edmond
and you accuse me of mlging these things
oh my God what are you holding am I
gonna rock oh my God you can equip a
rock yeah Rock kills okay
it's all okay X
all right
luggage is that luggage
someone just pointed out
I accidentally said our trials
anyway that's not important I think you
should
find some trees you meant the
protagonist yes that's what I meant
that's what I meant it was embodying the
protagonist
all right I was getting into it emotion
rocks luggage
don't forget some Doodles run past at
one point
so unless everything you keep an eye out
on the horizon okay
it's I think it's more or less
think so that would give me a a good
impression of this game
so Pond he was saying
but I didn't see any Pond when I was oh
man I never got collected
gonna get some sticks
oh Lucifer Jones says the starting point
is randomized oh no way
yes I can see the oh I can block
well then now that I know that there's a
block MLG
don't listen to that person's fighting
game
okay
all right so Pond it was saying
you're not yeah
so should we do you think it's an
advantage to pulling a shelter near the
water I don't think so I feel like water
didn't give us anything and also he
never gets thirsty okay well there are
the hearts again oh there's the pun oh
but do you want to build a shelter near
the Huts I wouldn't do we have
binoculars
you can probably craft some later oh I
see movement over there I see them
running across see that uh-huh I see it
um so should I build my shelter right
here while they walk towards me ah no I
don't think that's good oh okay
I'm glad you're here
there's four of them
you're outnumbered it was Mom and Dad
and two kids oh God don't say it like
that
actually yeah where is the mums like
I've only ever seen dudes on this island
so far there was that woman who was oh
wait no that was a guy
that was I think there might have been a
female face that was skewed oops did I
you just ate a poisonous berries good
job that was a bad idea
way over there they're not moving
I think you should hit B just quickly so
the prompts will go away okay
there you go well there's another Hut
there's more huts on your right be
careful
I noticed you didn't invert your mouse
for this Serene oh yeah is that why
you're doing so poorly it's because I'm
adaptable
okay there's another family of cannibals
on the other side of this life this must
be like the cannibal Town don't say
family say like army or something no out
to kill you these guys just want to
survive just like me
oh someone's body you can like totally
yeah in between the huts
wait was that another ax
sneak upon us again day six
is he just sleeping
nope not anymore
sweet dreams
yeah he had two left feet
I was gonna make the same joke
wait two out of 130 passengers found
oh what a thing just ticked off on the
bottom left wait was the person you just
chopped up a passenger oh my God are
these candles like
us they've been us all along oh God
don't say that
okay so I can't carry anymore six I
should probably try and
build a shelter but there yeah this is
where the animals live so I wouldn't be
able to show you yeah if this was me in
real life can you like can you hack at
the shelters and like dismantle yeah
let's burn their town where are you
gonna live now huh yeah
oh man that's deep Peter said the world
the world passengers on the plane of
laughs
I don't know if I can play this game
knowing that
is The Game of Life
it's all right this is a
an adaptation of the Hasbro board game
the game of Life the game
it's all right they hit you first
technically okay because they found your
plane they took your child
where do you want to build a shelter
what do you want to set up camp
um in a nice clearing on a cliff where
there's a vantage point you can look out
and yeah there's trees around so you can
easily collect more logs why do I keep
feeling like I'm hearing something
running up to us I think I hear a stream
can't hear anything here's a good
clearing yeah this looks like a good
area I like that peaceful Street there's
a rock
yeah all right we'll put ourselves to
buy this big rock
okay shelter temporary shelter hunting
shelter oh there's different types oh
build the Log Cabin 35 laws we're gonna
do a lot of shopping it's all right you
can do it in time you think you should
totally do it
log cabin all right do it we have to try
it at least once
go all right let's get to work
it's gonna be the best stream in the
world it's a game of labor now all right
you need to do this
uh
I'm gonna get hungry
no his stomach's still full he might as
well chopped out as many trees as you
can timber in fact just go from One Tree
it's gonna fall on the cabin oh god oh
it's all right I reckon you should just
chop everything right now and then
collect all the logs later in my own
town or rival the cannibal town why is
it not oh wait I think you need to place
it over there oh I see I'm doing it in
order yeah
all right
we'll build the Shelbyville to this
Springfield
yeah we've only got 78 traps everywhere
I wonder if this accent s your ability I
sure hope not
we're gonna need a bigger ax I wonder if
that that double-handed ax that you
found earlier and yeah
this is like a really crappy tiny ax
still I can fill a tree with this thing
yes it's a massive tree too not just any
small sapling
flip
sick it did like 7 20.
MLG wait Where'd I look him hello guys
I don't know that cabin where that other
log go
it's all right oh man it's shaping up
real good oh yeah it's gonna be sick
this rabbit's coming again there's an
iguana climbing up the tree get off that
tree oh my God
you're heartless man it was just living
its life chilling on the tree it was on
my tree man the hell why is that making
that sound totally thought you were
getting attacked for a moment
sorry we've only got 75 logs left to go
which if you divided by four is
approximately can we go off the chainsaw
or something I can't believe we're doing
this by the way
is Chad telling us to move on I hope so
no they're saying that they're enjoying
the uh chopping very much
no I have not seen Transformers yet if a
log falls on us do we get hurt that's a
big tree we need to get I hope you get
like 60 logs out of this you know what
would be the best if the logs fell into
place on top of the camera yeah has he
failed the trees
all righty look at this sick
that's gonna be awesome oh man it's got
windows and everything yeah
tin pin Pimpin house it's still on lions
says that they enjoy tree chops yeah
this is the stream for you I like that
every time I come in House of Horrors
it's never
we just end up doing stupid [__] like
this
it's what you're known for now I think
here we go
don't worry
yeah okay no logically speaking this
can't hurt us at all
dude jumping climbing and jumping of a
thing killed
us oh yeah man we're doing so good look
at him
you really come up in the world
I love how we just stack them all
together so neatly perfectly
this guy is a master Carpenter wait is
that a body
oh [__] maybe he was living in that tree
then we shut down
making the tree fell on
standing around you can use his arms to
build that Log Cabin
oh man
okay
that guy's coming looking for his friend
sis
should be Robin for his fire
I'm not wrong okay he's by himself wait
you're on low energy by the way so be
careful
oh it's
you're also on no you're full health I
can't tell yeah I think so I think the
red is definitely right okay
give me that fire where did he go oh
there he is you know I reckon you can
run up to him and he won't hear you
because that's what I did before
remember
and don't forget you can block as well
it's mad strats tactics
come here oh no you went fast up he has
no sorry [__]
die no face Boston there you go
far
okay
you put the fire out
whoa
rocket Johnson
that was amazing whatever happened there
it was awesome you fell into the sky I
fall into the sky okay and now I think
was excellent
oh okay oh
well this is Pleasant we're all in the
same boat here
shouldn't even bother attacking each
other we should reiterate that this game
is in Alpha so [__] like that will have
it yeah
so you gotta oh
he was like right there
so we gotta go back to building our
cabin so I'll see you guys later
I'll catch around you totally shouldn't
follow us we're not going yeah we're not
we're not going anything we're special
besides we had 66 logs left to go wait
how are we going to find it again I
don't okay we know it's near the um it's
on a hill yeah it's near the uh cannibal
town okay
um I need to eat something or get some
rest and get some health
absurda Source energy
um raw lizard or rabbit no I don't need
that anything in resource Health right
okay equip the ax
I see daylight out there so this is
going well
this is daylight and we can get out very
easily this
this
sticks
alrighty so we know the cannibals like
the keep their food in caves
good okay so wait what was that on the
distance
on the left
that white thing the rock oh
sorry I thought I saw a structure on the
lighter
how far can we possibly be from our Log
Cabin is that it in the distance
I think that's actually is it yeah
oh thank God
okay so we built our cabin right next to
the cave of mutants
um good plan it's all right they
wouldn't know what hit him okay
all right this is going well this is
good this is a good run this is a good
run yeah we've only got 66 logs left to
go yeah okay
yeah back to what we were doing
the important things like chopping down
there were a lot of cannibals there
you think they were just sleeping or do
you think their prisoners like us
well they didn't attack you but I feel
like if you hit one of them they all
would have started attacking
didn't take too kindly to people getting
attacked no who would have thought and
so the moral of the story is when you
kill a guy
don't walk on top of them otherwise we
get launched in the air I think I think
it's because I was chopping his limbs
logic and the limbs have had a physics
system of like springing up everywhere
like
this one ragdoll physics yeah you sound
like you know what you're talking
can't believe this game is built in
unity
wow it looks freaking amazing
wow that looks like a taro plant a taro
plant yeah you can make some bubble tea
this one yeah almost a bubble tea later
um we need to wash up our blood
oh no how did she get covered in blood
oh the guy you killed yeah after I
killed the guy I guess okay all right 62
left yeah sick okay
let me just chop off like a bunch of
trees at once
yeah I was saying chop them all at once
and then go around picking all the logs
up
hmm
no I think I tried to do that before
no he's a game of Labor
one to one ax swinging hey this is very
push Friday it certainly says in the way
man you get a mad workout playing that
yeah absolutely
look at this tree looks like a gum tree
can we cut it down No Maybe
oh goodness it's too old
crouched chop
let's see what people are seeing on the
twitters
um let's see
hrh live where are you
it's very satisfying to the full tree
like this aren't you glad we're building
a cabin air yeah whoa look how many logs
that one gave you log train
I'm very assisted in an attempt to build
the cabin away from the cannibal Village
they built it next to the cannibal cave
yeah that's okay yeah
I like him
I'll be cannibal cabin I like how
there's a logistics how do we get that
log up there
logically why was that the good place
oh yeah that makes sense I can see that
happening
up in the distance as well another
well there's another body on the ground
Jesus yeah I mean we're so close to the
um the cake
what if I can equip a log as a weapon
for he is a very strong dude Maybe
it's like a battering ram just like you
have enough body parts to make an effigy
now actually oh yeah yeah
well that's a good idea since we're
close to so many cannibal um
uh like thingies living areas what's the
word settlements settlements
um I don't think you should eat those
actually man it's gonna be the best
house do you think we can make it by
sundown yeah for sure
man TD TV Sandman says it was lag good
to clean the best place for it
I like your style
and in the
in the future oh Jesus
give me a hat I don't think that's a hat
oh what oh no it's happening again oh no
no
GG
was a failure we got very close we did
survive an extra day though yes we did
we did so um I guess
I guess but oh well that was the forest
you who are watching that is now
oh
I had been trapped I'm Serene T and this
is House of Horus uh thank you for
tuning in everyone that is a game that
is available on Steam Early Access right
now yes it's in very early access as you
could tell it's public Alpha release
0.03 they haven't even gone up to one
version one yet but it looks really cool
it's got some really cool ideas I think
I could yeah I think once I start
flashing those out yeah definitely log
cabins
um as usual let us know what you thought
about the stream in the comments below
or on the hrh love hashtag on Twitch uh
Twitter and on Twitch I guess if you
want to let us know right now we'll be
back again next week at the same time
and just we'll be back as well what are
you playing next week are we haven't
decided yet so it's a mystery vote now
let us know cool thanks for joining us
thank you everyone bye good week